so an author Pulitzer Prize finalist by
the way wrote on Twitter yesterday that
people should stop wearing red hats in
June not just Magga hats they should
stop wearing red hats in general any red
hat at all is is deeply triggering now
Rebecca makai said she said is anyone
else made really uncomfortable these
days by anyone wearing any kind of red
baseball cap like I see one and my heart
does weird stuff and then I realize and
then I she didn't say stuff she said the
S word and then I finally realized it
only says Titleist or whatever maybe
don't wear red caps anymore normal
people also for the love of God the
clever folks wearing make America read
again or whatever caps no you're making
everyone scared
don't do it if you're here to be
contrary an equivalent here would be
Western Hindus choosing not to use the
swastika the swastika symbol in public
despite it being sacred to their faith
because it would offend / frighten
people the Red Hat has become a symbol
of hate because of how it where its
wearers act you know I have to really
agree with Rebecca on this one I think
she makes a good point but I would go a
step further because personally I'm
frightened
at this point by anything red at all I
don't care I don't care what it is any
kind of red thing whatsoever I was I was
a just for example I was walking through
a garden the other day and and I came up
to a tomato plant and I just vomited all
over the tomato plant and wept and I
broke down in tears I cried there for 15
minutes because I was so triggered and
traumatized by the sight of the red
thing I panicked at a stop sign last
week which of course is red and I plowed
right into a whole group of people and
that's Trump's fault not mine red is
very frightening for me I'm like a bull
in a rodeo it's just is its it just
triggers me in that way so stop with all
the red people I'm I'm I'm an agreement
with that actually in all seriousness
the real truth is and I don't know if
I'm alone in this but when I see the red
hats I still I guess I'm stuck in the
90s
when I see Red Hat's I still think of
Fred Durst I don't think of Donald Trump
which is also pretty traumatizing
actually so I guess I don't know if I'm
that used to be if you didn't grow up in
the 90s you don't know this but Red
Hat's used to be a use that someone else
used to have that brand and Trump
co-opted it which i think is pretty
offensive okay so the Democrats somehow
are getting more extreme in their
anti-gun rhetoric maybe you didn't think
that was possible but but here we are
after that terrible mass shooting in
Texas on Saturday a psychotic killer as
I'm sure you heard went nuts and started
driving around murdering random people
killed seven people injured more than 20
absolutely horrible and the most
horrible thing about it is just how
completely normal
this has this has become you know we
talked about it every time this happens
it's the same thing we say you think
back 20 years ago any this sort of thing
seemed like it was much less frequent
and when it did happen it was a huge
news cycle for months afterward it
seemed like it's like the only thing you
talked about for months you think about
Columbine for instance but now it
happens and a couple days later we've
all moved on because we're just so used
to it and that's that's a that's a
terrible thing it shouldn't be normal
it's become normal but it shouldn't be
that's how it's become now Democrats
have their answer and their answer is
obviously to confiscate guns when in
many cases as with this case the real
answer would have been you know the in
in many of these cases there are warning
signs ahead of time and if the
appropriate people who are in a position
to do something had done something then
it probably wouldn't have happened so we
don't need to get into laws and policies
and everything else
we don't need additional laws if the
laws that were already in
place had been enforced and the people
who were in a position to do something
had done something then this might have
been prevented because that's the thing
about laws you can add you can you can
add 50 additional laws you can add a
hundred you could pass five hundred new
anti gun laws it wouldn't matter if
they're not enforced and if we're not
enforcing the ones we already have on
the books then what's the point of
adding new ones so we don't even need to
get into the ideological aspect of it
it's just we if we're not enforcing the
ones we already have in the books then
what's the point of additional laws in
this case it's not it's not a matter of
having enforced gun laws but it turns
out that the killer called the police he
was fired from his job on the day that
this happened he called the police
himself and his his job called the
police and apparently I think the FBI
was notified as well but nothing was
done and and then this happens so we
don't need to get into talking about gun
laws but of course we will and that's
what's happened over the last few days
now you you you may recall that up until
very recently Democrats pretended that
they were not interested in confiscating
guns they were very clear about that
that this is not what they're looking to
do they want common common-sense gun
regulations so on and so forth but
they're not looking to confiscate guns
now for the first time there they're
being relatively upfront about it as
upfront as these people are capable of
being anyway here's a better O'Rourke
talking to reporters on Saturday and
listen to what he had to say
you're talking about buybacks yeah so I
want to be really clear that that's
exactly what we're going to do Americans
will who own ar-15s ak-47s will have to
sell them to the government we're not
going to allow them to stay on our
streets to show up in our communities to
be used against us in our synagogues or
churches or mosques or Walmart's are our
public places and then on Twitter in
reaction to the news that the shooter
had used an ar-15 he said simply buy
them all back period buy them all back
now I call this only relatively upfront
it's more upfront the Democrats have
been in the past but it's only
relatively because the term buyback is
of course a euphemism it's like it would
be like if if I were to commit an armed
robbery and when the police come I said
hey it's was an armed robbery it was a
compelled donation is all it's the same
kind of thing a mandatory buyback which
is what the Dems want is the same as
confiscation it is confiscation by
another name it's the exact same thing
it's confiscation with maybe a financial
compensation tied to it but the problem
with the financial compensation is that
it does nothing to address the violation
of Rights the fundamental and you know
underlying violation of rights that
that's taking place you can't you can't
undo that by just giving someone money
so that's a problem and it's compelled
and the government is just in effect
giving you back your own money let's
remember that if the government has
money whatever money the government has
it has because it's taken it from you
and from me and so now they want to take
your guns and then give you money in
exchange but they're giving your own
money back to you so they're buying back
your gun with your money it's basically
like they're taking your gun and then
taking your wallet out of your back
pocket and taking a few dollars out of
your own wallet and saying here you go
here's that that's for your
here's for your trouble here here's for
the gun it's just it's completely absurd
meanwhile here's here's what Joe Biden
had to say about about guns the idea
that we don't have elimination of
assault-type weapons magazines that can
can hold multiple bullets in them is
absolutely mindless it is no violation
of the Second Amendment it is it's just
a bow to the special interest of the gun
manufacturers all right it's got to stop
now
yes obviously it's easy to make fun of
Joe Biden talking about magazines with
multiple bullets all magazines have
multiple bullets that's the point of a
magazine you might as well ban six-packs
that have more than one beer right
that's sort of the whole point of it so
once again the opponents of guns reveal
that they really know nothing about guns
which is a problem and it is a very
telling thing that almost everyone who
has a knowledge of the subject seems to
be in favor of gun rights
that's an interesting correlation there
but the the most significant thing aside
from the ignorance on display is just
that the the general anti-gun rhetoric
which is way more extreme indirect than
it's ever been before and what's really
troubling about that
the only reason why Democrats are doing
this right now on during the primary on
the campaign trail is because they sense
they know they've looked at the numbers
they've looked at the polls they've done
the focus groups and everything else
they have their internal polling data
and they know that at least on their
side of the aisle there is a real
appetite for this now so this was just a
few radical politicians going around say
god we got to confiscate all the guns I
wouldn't be worried about that what is
worrying is that this is a trend now
among Democratic politicians because
they are pandering to their base which
means there are millions of average
Americans who are in favor of this not
on my joy not a majority by any stretch
but they're out there I think it's a
certainly a growing number of the of the
mob now this is what they want and
that's what's really troubling that's
what we have to I think
worry about all right um moving on
here's a story that I've been wanting to
talk about for the last few days if I
can pull it up here
okay this is as reported by NPR it says
that the title is academic science
rethinks all too white dude walls of
honor
now that headline doesn't make a lot of
sense so this is what it says a few
years ago TV celebrity Rachel Maddow was
at TV celebrity Rachel Maddow you know
it's an interesting label for it was
that Rockefeller University to hand out
a prize that's given each year to a
prominent female scientists as Maddow
entered the auditorium someone overheard
her say what's up with the dude wall she
was referring to a wall covered with
portraits of scientists from the
University who have won either a Nobel
Prize or the Lasker Award a major
Medical Prize 100% of them are men it's
probably 30 headshots of 30 men so it's
imposing says Leslie Voss Hollen or
neurobiologist for the University and
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute Voss
Hall says Mao's remark and the word dude
wall crystallized something that has
been bothering her for years as she
travels around the country to give
lectures and attend conferences at
scientific institutions she constantly
encounters lobbies conference rooms
passageways and lecture hall lecture
halls that are decorated with portraits
of white men bas Hall says it just sends
the message every day when you walk by
it that science consists of old white
men I think every institution needs to
go out in the hallway and ask what kind
of message are we sending with these oil
portraits and dusty old photographs
she's now on a committee that's
redesigning the wall of portraits at
Rockefeller University to add more
diversity now I'm not gonna keep reading
from it but adding more diversity means
of course taking down some of those
portraits of those
of those dastardly old white men those
old white men who just so happened to
accomplish marvelous things and that's
how they earn their spot on that wall
but we're gonna take them down not
because they've been superseded in
accomplishment by somebody else but just
because they're they don't have the
right skin color or the right
reproductive organs so we're gonna take
down their portraits and put and put up
portraits of women or
you know people with with who don't have
white skin darker skin let's ask
ourselves though why do all of these
schools have all of these portraits or
why did they at least have all these
portraits of white male scientists and
doctors well and I'm gonna try to be as
as diplomatic as I can be what I say
this so as not to offend anyone but the
reason is that most of the greatest
scientists and medical pioneers in
history have been white males okay so I
just I want to emphasize that most in by
far in fact I mean this is an
understatement
by far most of the greatest scientists
in history have been white males not
exclusively but primarily that's just a
historical fact okay it just is you
think about the greatest scientists in
history I mean just whatever rattle off
the names that come immediately to your
head Newton Einstein Copernicus Galileo
Tesla Hawking you know Kepler Hubble
Herschel you know I'm blending time
periods and and and disciplines here but
you get the point most of the greatest
scientific minds in history have been
white men that's a reality we could talk
about why that is and that's a different
discussion that's an interesting
discussion um but but that's that's not
the discussion we're having here what
I'm simply establishing is that it is
I'm not talking about why it is I'm
saying that it is as for why what I will
say is this you can't
that well white men were the only ones
who had the opportunity to invent modern
science the only ones who could do it
because of the patriarchal and racist
societies of the past so they're the
only ones who had the chance and and so
they're the ones who did it no let me
tell you something Isaac Newton okay
did not become Isaac Newton as we know
him today because he benefited from the
patriarchy Isaac Newton is Isaac Newton
because he was a towering genius the
genius level of a guy like Isaac Newton
newson the genius level I I never said
that I was a genius the genius level the
force the force of his genius is what
made him a scientific revolutionary and
that's all okay there's no additional oh
he had he had help from the patriarchy
no this was just a if you understand how
incredibly brilliant this guy was you
know he went into a room and thought
about an invented calculus okay that's
safer Einstein and Copernicus and these
other guys just so incredibly brilliant
and that's why their scientific you know
pioneers and that's why they get the
credit for that but here's the point now
what I also would not say we talk about
okay so we have the fact that most most
of the greatest scientists in history
have been white men not all but most the
the question of why is a different
question I'm not getting into that what
I will say it's not that well white men
are superior or smarter generally and
that's why they're they're the ones who
did oh no I'm not saying that that's
that's not the case and and I think one
of the one of the ridiculous things
about white supremacist the those that
do exist is that it's it's like they're
trying to take credit for things that
other people did so I you know the
Newton was a genius I would love if I
could take some of that credit and say
oh yeah
you know he was on my team as a white
man so I get some credit too you know we
we we did it now it wasn't a we he
happened to be a white guy and he did he
was the genius he did I didn't do it I
don't get any credit for that that's
aside from the the the moral the the
moral derangement of the white
supremacist viewpoint
one of the other problems with it is
just that you have these people who
haven't done anything but you know post
on message boards and play video games
that are trying to take credit for these
things that people other than themselves
have done so that's not the case but
it's just a simple fact that white men
most of the great scientists have been
white men here's the main point though I
don't see this as a point of shame or
embarrassment okay we are now told that
we should be ashamed and we should be
embarrassed that white men have done so
much good in the world and it's an
interesting message because on one hand
we're told Oh white men are toxic
bullies and oppressors and on the other
hand we're essentially told they've done
too much good in the world they've
contributed too much too medicine and
science so we have to take down their
portraits and pretend that they didn't
do it because it's it's not fair they
didn't give anyone else a chance but I
don't think embarrassment or or anything
like that is the right emotion I I would
suggest a different emotion maybe
gratitude maybe we should be grateful
for what these men have accomplished not
because they're men or because they're
white but just because of what they
accomplished maybe we should be grateful
for that rather than whining that they
didn't have you know different
reproductive organs or darker skin why
don't we have gratitude for what they
did and what they accomplished and how
easier they made our lives through the
invention of modern science I think
probably that's a better reaction than
one of embarrassment or shame or
resentment jealousy envy because I think
it's great if you want to if you if
you're saying well we need to get more
women involved in science fine great go
for it
but when we start taking down and
covering up the portraits and the
statues so that they don't feel bad
that's that's that's not the right
message when you if you have a young
woman entering a university she wants to
be a scientist she should be looking up
to these guys you got to keep their
portraits up because you could say look
at what these incredible people achieved
maybe you could do the same
so it's aspirational but you lose that
effect if you start taking it down and
hiding it and saying oh don't worry
about them
[Music]
and it's it's absurd anyway because if
you're if you're if you're in a school
and you're trying to get into the
sciences and you're learning and you're
reading text books these these white men
whose portraits you've covered up or
taken down they're gonna be all over the
textbooks because like I said these are
mostly the people who invented modern
science so you can't escape them even if
you want to all right there's one other
thing I wanted to do I have time you
have time
one other thing I wanted to talk about
another article I wanted to read
partially in mainly because it raises a
question I've had for a while and maybe
you guys can help me out with it this is
this is just a question that I have I
don't fully understand it from CBS News
that set of casts as a Catholic school
in Nashville Tennessee has banned the
Harry Potter series because a reverend
at the school claims the books include
both good and evil magic as well as
spells which if read by a human can
conjure evil spirits according to The
Tennessean the publication obtained an
email from Reverend Dan
he'll a pastor at st. edward's Catholic
school Paris which was sent to parents
an email real explains that he consulted
several exorcists in the US and in Rome
and it was recommended that the school
removed the books The Tennessean reports
revenue Hill said of the Harry Potter
series these books represent or present
magic as both good and evil which is not
true but in fact a clever deception the
curses and spells used in the books are
actual or actual curses and spells which
would which when read by human being
risk conjuring evil spirits into the
presence of the person reading the text
and then it goes on how they other
parents had complained and so on and
that's and so they took out the Harry
Potter books i-i've heard this from
other from other people that the spells
the magic spells in Harry Potter are
quote actual magic spells are they
though having actual magic spells
because I don't think magic spells exist
in reality have you ever seen anyone say
a magic spell and then something magical
happens have you ever seen that in your
life I never have you know that's
something that exists in in fantasy
books so that's not a real thing so but
this problem with Harry Potter this is a
among some Christians a not
insignificant number of Christians in my
experience some Christians are very
uncomfortable with Harry Potter
and maybe that's understating it but I
have to say that I don't understand it
personally I'm not a Harry Potter fan I
think quality wise it's nothing special
but this and I haven't read it and yes I
do say that even though I haven't read
it I mean I also haven't read Twilight
or or you know Fifty Shades of Grey but
I feel confident that I can say those
are not literary classics even though I
haven't read them Harry Potter I'm not
gonna say is had quite down at that
level but I don't think it's at the
level of something like Lord of the
Rings but this idea that it's some house
spiritually dangerous that I don't get
yes there are magic spells or evil
spirits evil forces all that but but all
of that exists being a Lord of the Rings
all of that exists in Lord of the Rings
- and I get that talking talking was a
was a was a Christian and there are some
Christian elements in the Lord of the
Rings Lord of the Rings is not a
Christian allegory as some people like
to claim Tolkien himself was clear that
it was not that was it meant to be that
but he was a Christian a devout
Christian so yeah that's true but still
it's a fantasy story dealing with good
and evil forces and magic spells and so
on and so forth just like Harry Potter
so why is Harry Potter a problem but not
Lord of the Rings I don't quite
understand that I think here's what I
say I think the depiction of evil in a
story whether it's magical evil or
ordinary everyday evil really doesn't
much matter the depiction only becomes
problematic when the evil is either
glorified or when we're given sort of a
nihilistic view where there's really no
difference between good and evil and
they all blend together and in the end
there is no good or evil I think both of
those are problems especially for kids
so I would agree with that and I'm not
saying there's anything inherently
absurd about you know being concerned
about a fiction story because I also
think this idea that well it's all it's
just make-believe it doesn't matter what
happens in the story no I don't think
that's true at all it definitely matters
and people are shaped and formed and
influenced by the stories they read this
is part of human nature it's been the
case ever since the dawn of human
civilization we tell stories and this is
one of the things that moves and
motivates and as I said forms us so it
does matter what those stories contain
and what sort of stories we're dealing
with but I think that's where it becomes
a problem where there is no difference
between good and evil or where evil is
actually glorified and there are many
examples of both of those things both in
modern literature and in modern
television and movies and everything
else
my understanding is that Harry Potter
and as I said haven't read it I've seen
a little bit of some of the movies but
that's all my understanding is that
Harry Potter is a pretty straightforward
good character and the story is all
about his struggle his ultimately
successful struggle right against the
bad guys so there's no problem as far as
that's concerned I mean our kids likely
to read Harry Potter and come away
identifying with Waldo Mort
come away rooting for Volta Mort to win
I you do see that with some fictional
stories with where the bad guys are kind
of cooler and those are the ones the
kids identify with what about what about
Darth Vader when I was a kid I was never
a big star Wars fan but I definitely
thought like most people I thought Darth
Vader was by far the coolest Star Wars
character I still I still think he is
but you never hear Christians worrying
about Star Wars there you've got you've
got magical forces you got the force
right bad Jedi's good Jedi's you've got
Darth Vader who's the cool bad guy that
everyone sort of is more interested in
yet as I said Christians aren't worried
about that and so I don't quite
understand it now there's a trend on the
other side of the coin to get rid of
literary classics like Huckleberry Finn
and so on because it isn't politically
correct and because it has language that
is that's they say is problematic the
stuff with Harry Potter though I don't
think that Harry Potter is a literary
classic but this stuff seems a little
like the Christian version of that if
we're gonna say and I do say that books
with the n-word books such as Mark Twain
books with the n-word in it should be
allowed to stay on the shelves in
schools because kids can be expected to
take that in context and understand it
in its context if we're gonna say that
then can't we expect kids to understand
magical spells in their context namely
the context of make-believe
there's a there's an interesting thing
there but I I welcome your emails on
that subject and I'm sure I will receive
them Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com if you can I
would be interested if a Christian could
explain to me why Harry Potter is a
spiritual problem but Lord of the Rings
and Star Wars for example or not that
that's the specific question I would
like to read and answer to and maybe
I'll find out that there's a good answer
I just don't know what it is all right
Matt well show at gmail.com his email
address let's answer a few emails this
is from Terry says Matt I agree with you
about FaceTime in public but what about
speakerphone is that better or worse we
talked about this on Twitter a few days
ago I was saying that that and this
should be obvious I shouldn't need to
say it I can't believe I need to say it
but using FaceTime in public is
completely outrageously inappropriate
and it's an absolute jerk move to do
that yet in it seems to me in my
experience that that this is becoming
more and more common where you've got
where you've got people that are you
know sitting in a coffee shop or
something like that and and they've got
their little pal on FaceTime talking to
them as if they're in the room like put
just pick up the phone and talk to them
you don't need to see their face the
whole time now is it is that is is it
like speaker four no speakerphone is
actually worse because there's really no
reason for that and there are people who
do that too they'll sit there in public
talking on speakerphone you in that case
you can't even see their face so there's
really no reason at all to not just pick
up the phone and talk to them we don't
all need to hear the conversation now I
know the the answer is well what's the
difference between sitting at a coffee
shop you've got someone on FaceTime
talking to them
what's the difference between that and
having an actual person sitting you know
in the chair well I think there's a
difference the FaceTime is louder just
the tone and everything it's louder you
can hear it more if you're not involved
in the conversation and it's also
completely unnecessary if you really
want to see that person's face face then
go to wherever they are and talk to them
one excuse I've heard from people is
well I travel a lot and so I have to
FaceTime my kids okay I travel a lot too
but you know what that's not an excuse
you can go to your hotel room and
FaceTime them you can go somewhere and
private and FaceTime if you if you
really need to FaceTime in public you
know what just talk to them on the phone
and while you're talking to them to your
kids just stare at a Polaroid of them or
so have a little Polaroid Polaroid
picture
you remember those and just look at the
picture while you're talking - how about
that it's no excuse this is from Danny
says hi Matt as a Catholic I take it you
are not a fan of Martin Luther correct
Danny but I am interested in your take
on this quote from him that I ran across
recently and the quote is reason must be
deluded blinded and destroyed faith must
trample underfoot all reason sense and
understanding and whatever it sees must
be put out of sight and no nothing but
the Word of God
unquote what do you think should faith
come before reason or reason before
faith yes Danny as with so many other
things I I must disagree with Martin
Luther here and in fairness that quote
there I'm sure there's a larger context
to it and I don't have the context here
so I'm just engaging with it as its
presented out of its context taking it
like that I would disagree with it I
think it's a big problem to sort of put
faith over here and then reason and
understanding over here as if they're
two completely different categories of
things and then to say that they're at
odds with each other
and we should choose one or the other I
think that's a problem that's the
stereotype of faith the negative view of
faith the negative version that we get
from
atheists when I hear Christians
confirming it it really makes me cringe
and I do hear this by putting this
Martin Luther quote aside I hear this
kind of thing from Christians sometimes
if we have to choose faith over a reason
sense and understanding how do we if
you're if you're saying well I have
faith completely apart from your reason
your sense and your understanding then
what do you mean that you have faith
what does that even mean in that in that
context what does it mean to say I think
this proposition is true that there is a
God that Jesus is the Son of God the
Bible is the Word of God etc what does
it mean to say that you think that
proposition is true if if you are
accepting it apart from reason and
understanding what does that mean I
think it's true well you can't think
anything without reason and you can't
understand the distinction between truth
and falsehood without reason that's what
you use your reason for it's what makes
us human to call something true is a
judgment of reason it seems to me all of
these things are linked is what I'm
saying I I just I don't think you can
neatly separate them and put them into
different compartments and different
categories I just don't see how you can
do that look if someone asks you why do
you believe in God which if you're a
believer I assume you have been asked
that question many times and it's
certainly a question that you must be
prepared to answer so what do you say
when you're asked that question I guess
you could say well I just feel like it's
true I feel it but that would be a very
unconvincing answer that will leave you
by the way totally exposed to the
obvious follow up from your let's say
atheist questioner the obvious follow-up
is well I feel like God isn't true and
Hindus feel like their God their God is
true and Muslims feel like their God is
true and the ancient pagans felt like
their gods
true and you know tribesmen in the
Amazon feel like their gods are true if
all you have are your feelings then how
do you know that your feelings are more
true than anyone elses it does no good
to say why I just really really feel it
and I and I assume that they must not
feel it over their misunderstanding
their feelings or something how do you
know that you can't say that you have no
idea you you've only experienced the
world through your own mind you've only
had your own feelings you just you
cannot make those kinds of statements
about other people so that's that's why
it would be a problem and that's if if
you're trying to answer that question
why do you believe in God if you're
trying to answer it totally apart from
fit from reason understanding and sense
then it seems like that could be that's
the only answer you have left it's just
I you know I sort of feel it but
probably probably that's not what you
would say or that's prep that's probably
not what you have said when you've been
asked this question if you're asked why
you think God is true why God is real
probably you give some answer that
hinges on reason and certainly it
certainly it must hinge on on sense and
understanding I mean even saying I feel
like it's true or whatever that's a
sense another way of putting that is I
sense that it's true so it seems to me
that's kind of what faith is it's a it's
a it's a certain spiritual sense of the
truth of of this thing so to put to even
save faith without sense and well now
you're really now I just have no idea
what faith is if it's not even sensed
and what the hell is it pardon the
expression
so I I I would show anyone anyone who
would agree with that quote I would
challenge you to come up with a
definition of faith that is completely
separate from any notion of sense
understanding or reason I don't think
you can I don't think you could come up
with with it I don't think you come up
with a coherent intelligible definition
of faith that has nothing to do with any
of those things so I think we we just
create a false dichotomy here
like I said our I think any any time you
come to the conclusion that something is
true your reason is always involved in
that always that's kind of the
definition of what reason is well that's
that's part of it anyway is the ability
to contemplate the truth or falsehood of
a particular idea or proposition and and
come to a conclusion you know animals
can't do that weekend because we have
the ability to reason so and and that is
very much involved in in our you know in
faith as well it's it would seem to me
so even when you read the Bible for
example when you read the Gospels and
you say to yourself you know it really
seems to me that this is true that's
faith but it's also reason what do you
mean it seems to you it obviously seems
to you as reasonable it seems to you as
something that is true so that's your
reason talking there even just the
ability to understand what you're
reading but you couldn't possibly read
the Bible without reason you literally
couldn't read it you wouldn't know you
wouldn't be able to put together what
any of the words even mean to be able to
read words and understand what they mean
is reason all right
so we'll we'll leave it there I suppose
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20:19 if
you want to delve the depths of leftist
madness head on over to the Michael
Noel's show where we examine what's
really going on beneath the surface of
our politics and bask in the simple joys
of being right
[Music]